[Music]
send me somebody that was many of these
music competition shows are they're
getting questions because it's hard for
these people to make it after they come
off the show so what are you guys doing
to really ensure that these competitors
come off and and they have an edge in
the industry I think it's put into
working to like what Evie who won who
was our first winner I never won her to
jump right into the studio I think
people don't take the time to do the
artist development so we put her through
the artist development phase getting it
to understand how voice and arrange and
I think it's the investment that you
make in two people that that will
develop them and make sure that they go
on their journey to become a star and
we're all committed today the four is
back for season two beginning Thursday
June 7th on Fox ahead of the premiere ET
sat down with Fergie Diddy DJ Khaled and
Meghan Trainor to get a little insight
into their pre-show rituals I go like
this to everyone and we go the one I
could do it
nice song Khaled I'm the one I'm the one
and then I drank tea and I kissed my
fiance and i high-five every family
member who's there and say this is for
you
what about you it's riding on a golf
cart okay the stage with Khaled like I
can't go to the stage there's this place
we go to right before we hit the stage
and there's it's kind of like a little
bit of an area before we walk out and
usually duty will come out and do a
blessing and we'll just kind of get in
the huddle do a blessing we pray like
she said before we actually touch the
stage so you know just getting up
praying and really just I'm sitting in
that trailer I'm like man
to come a long way man grateful for this
opportunity what about your post show
must have how do you wind down after man
you know I'm but my sir it's a lot of
hours and I sit back in the car and I
get driven new saying go home and I'm
like man put the window down and really
you know embrace it then I tell Tina
said brother Clough don't call me like
that bout 30 or 45 minutes every night
is that you to get a crib gonna call and
I just wanna chill man you know Sam
first things first
of course it like any hair extensions
that are being wrapped right yeah the
coarser I didn't depression freshen up
I'm usually going straight home to my
bed because I've got to be up the next
day yeah mom duty calls
yeah I can't say no I really can't
when I get my way my guys the guy we
know it's not awake yes it is
I'll tell you this is not my hair I
don't believe you but we're gonna move
on okay
[Music]